>>> THE NATION'S TWO LARGEST
RIDE SHARE COMPANIES, LYFT AND
UBER, ARE BOTH PUSHING BACK
AGAINST TEXAS'S NEW RESTRICTIVE
ABORTION LAW THAT EFFECTIVELY
BANS ABORTIONS AFTER SIX WEEKS
AND GIVES PRIVATE CITIZENS THE
RIGHT TO FILE CIVIL LAWSUITS
AGAINST ANYONE CONSIDERED TO BE
AIDING IT AN ABORTION.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE ANYONE WHO
DRIVES A WOMAN TO A MEDICAL
CENTER, FOR EXAMPLE.
NOW LYFT AND UBER SAY THEY WILL
COVER THE LEGAL FEES OF DRIVERS
WHO MIGHT FACE ANY LAWSUITS FOR
THAT.
LYFT HAS ALSO DONATED A MILLION
DOLLARS TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD IN
THE WAKE OF THIS.
THE COMPANY'S COFOUNDER SENT A
LETTER TO EMPLOYEES.
LET ME READ YOU PART OF IT.
QUOTE, WE WANT TO BE CLEAR,
DRIVERS ARE NEVER RESPONSIBLE
FOR MONITORING WHERE THEIR
RIDERS GO AND WHY.
IMAGINE BEING A DRIVER AND NOT
KNOWING IF YOU'RE BREAKING THE
LAW BY GIVING SOMEONE A RIDE.
RIDERS SHOULD NEVER HAVE TO
JUSTIFY WHERE THEY'RE GOING.
IMAGINE BEING A PREGNANT WOMAN
B.
I SHOULD NOTE THE NEW TEXAS LAW
TOO EXTREME EVEN FOR SOME
PRO-LIFE REPUBLICANS.
LISTEN TO WHAT CONGRESSMAN ADAM
KINZINGER TOLD OUR DANA BASH
JUST YESTERDAY.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT THE SUPREME COURT
THING MEANT.
FOR ME I'M PRO-LIFE.
WHAT I DON'T LIKE TO SEE IS THIS
IDEA OF SEEING EVERY CITIZEN
BEING ABLE TO TATTLE.
SUE AN UBER DRIVER BE DEPUTIZED
TO ENFORCE THIS ABORTION LAW TO
WHATEVER THEY WANT.
>> LET ME BRING IN THE GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR LYFT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING.
IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME, POPPY.
>> SO IT WAS LYFT THAT DECIDED
TO DO THIS.
UBER JOINED ON LITERALLY AN HOUR
LATER.
SO BOTH MAJOR COMPANIES ARE NOW
ON BOARD.
BUT CAN YOU BRING US INTO THE
DECISION-MAKING ROOM?
HOW DID YOU GUYS MAKE THIS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WELL FIRST AND FOREMOST, AS YOU
SAID, THIS LAW IS EGREGIOUS.
AND IT BANS VIRTUALLY EVERY
ABORTION IN THE STATE OF TEXAS
AND ENCOURAGES PRIVATE CITIZENS
TO SUE ONE ANOTHER.
SO LATE WEDNESDAY NIGHT, AFTER
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
FAILED TO ENJOIN THE LAW, OUR
PRESIDENT AND CEO REACHED OUT
AND SAID WHAT CAN WE DO ABOUT
THIS.
AND A SMALL GROUP OF US
IMMEDIATELY CONVENED.
I WAS VERY HEARTENED TO SEE THIS
FROM TWO MALE CO-FOUNDERS
UNDERSTAND THIS LAW'S IMPACT ON
A WOMEN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
AND VERY QUICKLY WE DECIDED THAT
WE WANTED TO ACT.
WE WERE ALSO HEARING FROM
DRIVERS WHO WERE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT THIS MEANS FOR THEM.
ARE THEY UNDER SOME OBLIGATION
TO MONITOR WHERE THEY ARE RIDERS
ARE GOING AND WHY.
AND SO WE BOTH WANTED TO COME
OUT STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE AS WELL
AS MAKE OUR DRIVERS FEEL OKAY.
WE DID NOT WANT THEM BEING IN
THIS UNTENABLE POSITION OF NOT
KNOWING WHETHER THEY'RE BEHAVIOR
WAS OKAY OR NOT.
AND SO WITHIN THAT FIRST 24
HOURS, WE DECIDED WHAT WE WERE
GOING TO DO AND WE WERE LUCKY TO
HAVE STRONG SUPPORT FROM OUR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS, INCLUDING
VALERIE JARRETT WHO WE DISCUSSED
WITH AND SHE SAID I ONLY WISH I
HAD THOUGHT OF IT MYSELF.
>> IT IS INTERESTING THAT A LOT
OF THIS ALSO WAS PROMPTED BY
DRIVERS BEING CONCERNED.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR ME.
AM I GOING TO BE ON THE THE HOOK
FOR $10,000 AND POTENTIAL CIVIL
PROSECUTION.
WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW, KRISTEN,
AS YOU KNOW, FOLLOWING THIS MOVE
IN TEXAS, IS THAT A NUMBER OF
REPUBLICAN-LED STATES.
MORE THAN HALF A DOZEN ARE
LOOKING TO FOLLOW TEXAS' PATH
HERE.
AND PASS SIMILAR LAW THAT'S THE
SUPREME COURT AT THIS POINT
HASN'T INTERVENED AND DOESN'T
KNOW IF IT HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
CHECK BECAUSE WE'RE IN
INCHARTERED TERRITORY.
IF THAT HAPPENS, IS LYFT'S
PROMISE TO COVER ALL OF THE
LEGAL FEES FOR ANY DRIVER
INDEFINITE AND WOULD IT SPAN ALL
OF THOSE STATES?
>> THAT IS OUR INTENTION, YES,
POPPY.
OBVIOUSLY EVERY STATE MAY ENACT
ITS OWN LAWS.
THIS TEXAS LAW IS UNIQUE IN THAT
IT HAS THIS PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION WHICH IS AS WE JUST HEARD
ON THE CLIP A BOUND TOO FOR FOR
EVEN REPUBLICAN CONGRESS PEOPLE.
BUT, YES, LYFT WANTS TO SUPPORT
ITS DRIVERS IN THIS.
THE OVER BREADTH NATURE OF THE
LAW WHERE IT SAID THAT ANYONE
COULD BE LIABLE FOR AIDING OR
ABETTING IS JUST UNIQUE AND IT
IS EGREGIOUS.
AND SO THAT IS WHY WE WANTED TO
COME OUT STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
OUR DRIVERS AND STRONGLY AGAINST
THIS LAW.
>> LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION
THAT IS NOT LEGAL.
BUT YOU'RE A HIGH-RANKING
EXECUTIVE AT THE COMPANY AND IT
IS VERY INTERESTING AND WE'RE IN
A NEW SORT OF PHASE OF
CORPORATIONS SPEAKING OUT AND
ACTING ON SOCIAL ISSUES THAT ARE
VERY DIVISIVE LIKE ABORTION.
YOU WON'T HAVE SEEN THIS I THINK
FIVE OR TEP YEARS AGO.
AND YOU HAVE POLLING THAT SHOWS
42% OF RESIDENTS IN TEXAS FOR
EXAMPLE SUPPORT BANNING ABORTION
AFTER A FETAL HEARTBEAT FOR
EXAMPLE.
NOT SPECIFICALLY THIS LAW, BUT
THAT IN GENERAL.
HOW DO YOU WEIGH THAT AS A
COMPANY?
BECAUSE FOR SURE ALL OF YOUR
CUSTOMERS AND EMPLOYEES, DRIVERS
WILL NOT AGREE WITH THIS.
>> YES, THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION.
AND WHEN WE DISCUSSED THIS
DECISION, WE KNEW THAT IT COULD
BE CONTROVERSIAL AND WE KNEW
THAT WE WOULD NOT SEE 100%
SUPPORT BUT THIS IS VERY MUCH A
MOMENT OF WANTING TO DO WHAT IS
RIGHT, WHAT WE AS THE EXECUTIVES
AT LYFT FELT WAS RIGHT AND I'M
VERY PROUD OF US FOR HAVING DONE
THIS.
WE WILL LOSE SOME CUSTOMERS
BECAUSE OF IT.
BUT THAT WAS NOT -- THAT WAS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WAS GOING TO STOP
US FROM ACTING HERE.
>> IT'S NOTABLE BECAUSE IT
FOLLOWS OTHER DECISIONS AND
MOMENTS OF SPEAKING OUT ON
SOCIAL ISSUES THAT LYFT HAS MADE
FOR EXAMPLE IN 2019 YOU GAVE A
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE ACLU
AFTER TRUMP ISSUED THE TRAVEL
BAN AND YOU'VE TAKEN A STAND ON
A NUMBER OF ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES.
IS IT LYFT'S POSITION THAT THE
ROLE AND RESPONSIBILITY OF
FOUNDERS AND CEOs IN AMERICA IS
CHANGING ON SOCIAL ISSUES THAT
YOU ARE NOT DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THEIR BUSINESS, THAT THEY NEED
TO SPEAK OUT ON THEM?
>> YES, I THINK THAT IS RIGHT,
POPPY.
YOU KNOW, I JOINED LYFT NEARLY
NINE YEARS AGO AFTER WORKING AS
THE COMPANY'S OUTSIDE COUNSEL
AND ONE OF THE REASONS THAT I
JOINED THE COMPANY AND I STAYED
AS LONG AS I HAVE IS BECAUSE WE
ARE VALUES LED.
PROBABLY NINE YEARS AGO WE WOULD
NOT HAVE SPOKEN OUT ON THIS
ISSUE.
AND HONESTLY, AS I THINK BACK ON
IT, I'M NOT SURE WHY, ABORTION
IS A CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHT AND SO I'M HAPPY TO SEE US
TAKE A VOICE AND I HOPE THAT
MORE OF CORPORATE AMERICA DOES
THIS.
AND GOVERNMENTS SHOULD BE
PASSING FAIR LEGISLATION AND NOT
LOOK AT -- TO INAPPROPRIATELY
BAN A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS THEY
HAVE HERE.
BUT I DO THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT CORPORATE AMERICA HOLDS
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE AND
SPEAKS OUT IN IMPORTANT ISSUES.
>> WELL, I THINK IF WE'VE
LEARNED ANYTHING IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS IT IS HOW MUCH POWER
CORPORATE AMERICA DOES HAVE ON
KEY ISSUES LIKE THIS.
KRISTI